i also wanted to talk to you about
uh you know you you and now like you
guys have a dope chemistry obviously
shout out to stockton
um how did you guys outside of being
asian
and being from the west coast because
it's almost like
yeah of course they would do a project
together right like or two rather
and um yeah like talk about y'all's
relationship and and um
you know you guys got to relate to each
other because you guys kind of
are both some you know listen like you
said earlier
being an asian dude rapping it catches
people off guard a little bit yeah
uh i feel like like like i didn't
like know him before the music but when
i seen his first song i was just like
i relate to you know we both asian both
crips whatever i got a hood and my
neighborhood
down here is also in stockton and
i asked the homies hey man i'm gonna do
something with this dude um
he hard as [ __ ] y'all dude like is there
a policies between that there was no
politics so we linked
and it was just love and it was just
like the [ __ ] i talk about is really
really really real like from my area and
the [ __ ] he talk about is really real
from his area you know what i'm saying
so i just it's just and then we lean
just good chemistry from there
that's that's dope um yeah
shout out to him man um i feel like both
y'all got your wave
and then the yellow tape was just a a
very genius uh
for sure dom kennedy had a yellow tape
did you know that when you guys did that
no i didn't think about nobody when we
did that i feel like you'll fit us more
i was going to say
i was about to say you really can't like
what you really can't
nobody can say [ __ ] yeah but yeah i get
it i get it
yeah i get it you know what i've said